and we start with a look at i-15 and
sahara as you can see now things are
moving along
key ramp there is back open again after
being shut down this morning
but it wasn't for a crash we thank you
very much for joining us here on 8 news
now i'm john langler bianca holman is
live at i-15 in sahara to explain
why this key part of the road was off
limits most of the morning bianca
hey good morning good afternoon john so
yeah this busy stretch of road right
here
from the 15 exiting here on sahara it
was
closed and it was closed to protect
drivers because there was some damage
here on the ramp
that was from overnight into the morning
hours so it's unclear the extent of that
damage and what caused it
but crews had to close eastbound sahara
flyover it was closed for several hours
some people seeing it cold before
midnight even people seeing it close
around 4 00 a.m
and people were forced to use alternate
routes commuters had to
again try to find alternate routes
heading maybe
on the westbound sahara and making a
u-turn at rancho and valley view
another option for drivers uh taking the
exit at highland drive
which puts folks right at the uh right
at the
corridor there of the resorts right
there at the las vegas boulevard
now again we've looked into uh why this
happened why this is closed it's still
under investigation but of course once
we find out the cause
and the extent of that damage we will
keep you updated on
blind and here on era again this area is
now back over in the eastbound farbel
ram
to sahara reporting live ian holman 8
news now